hey everyone this is Steve landro with
collider and we are here at our studio
at the cinema center at marble and uh
hopefully I said it right because I've
been butchering it all day
um listen I'm so excited to talk to the
two of you thank you so much for coming
into our studio and congrats on being
part of Tiff
um Vigo I'm going to start with you uh
you this is your second feature and I'm
curious and it's such a different kind
of movie than your first film
um talk a little bit about why I
apologize I want to go backwards there's
going to be a ton of people watching
this that have won't have know much
about it how have you been describing it
to like friends and family the movie I
don't know if I have been I was just
that I've told another story and you
know I hope you will want to see it if I
had to describe it
um yeah that's true it's a it's a story
about a woman essentially but it's a
it's it's a love story
centered around uh the female character
and it's a in the western genre westerns
you know western movies are usually
about
taming the frontier or
you know expanding the frontier of the
nation or establishing what the
Frontiers are
and I thought that would be a perfect
setting
in which to tell a story that's
essentially about a woman who is
creating New Frontiers just by being
herself I definitely want to ask you
um this had to have been for you like a
fantastic script when you read it just
because your character is so
three-dimensional and goes through so
much and
um is funny and adventurous like talk a
little bit about what it was like
reading the script and was it an
immediate yes
yes
it was a yes before even I had a I don't
know
it sounds crazy but it's true I had
I was in the desert of Arizona
thinking suddenly okay if there's
anything I would like to do it would be
a western and I saw myself on a horse
and the same week I get an email by my
French agent
that Mr
would like to uh talk to me which was
already cool but I didn't know what for
and then it was uh this script and it
was a western
which was crazy because just before I
had thought about that and um
and then I read the script and as you
say that was easy to say yes because it
was a very complex story of a woman it
was full of
themes and uh this is uh like topics
that I as a woman want to talk about
that I think are important to talk about
I thought it was an interest into
interesting setting in the western
society which seems to me like the
most basic
construction of society that we still
have you know we are still constructing
Society in the same way but that's when
they started inventing it in a way you
know oh we need someone to to have this
little shop and then one does the thing
and then one and the roles were given to
people and the role of the woman and so
I thought that would be an interesting
setting for it yeah one of the things
that I enjoyed the most out of the film
were just the relationship between the
two of you and the sparse but yet funny
and unusual dialogue how much was that
in your script and how much was that
found on set well it was it was in there
it wasn't like we were improvising the
script we you know we stuck to the
script but it's one thing to write
something and have a certain idea of
where it can go and you hope maybe
there'll be some lightness sometimes but
it's not until someone is actually
playing
say the role of Vivian where you see the
possibilities I mean this is a the
character of Vivian
I thought this this is a woman who yes
she's vulnerable but she's also very
strong sometimes stubborn very much her
own person
not someone who's particularly vain who
just
sees a way she wants to be or something
she wants to do and she just does it
regardless of what the constraints are
she's I was I needed someone ideally
who was as
potentially unconventional and brave as
the character and I couldn't imagine
anybody better than Vicky so I was
hoping that you would want to travel no
no no no I mean I knew that if you said
yes I had a feeling that it would also
be trouble but trouble is good for this
kind of work you know and it's like and
sometimes and sometimes people like they
like to put things in a category okay
it's a feminist Western I never said
that but
the idea of feminine masculine it's a
complex thing more and more so these
days people talk about it more openly
but you know sometimes a man can be very
feminine and a woman can be more
masculine in their approach to a certain
problem or a discussion and you see that
in our characters they fluctuate you
know it's like even after their first
night together
she's like wow that was fun but now in
the light of day he seems like an idiot
and so one of the first questions he
says so when are you leaving and he's
like who says I'm leaving and he smiles
and she thinks oh maybe he does have
some balls okay maybe it's interesting
maybe I can
get to know him a little bit more before
I completely kick him out you know so I
like this back and forth you know
sometimes one is stronger than the other
and there's a is it kind of a right tug
of war one of the things that I also
enjoyed was the non-linear structure of
the film and I'm curious was that always
in the script and when you were in the
editing room did you try a version where
it wasn't as non-linear where it was
more do you know what I mean because
sometimes you can write it and it might
not work so I'm just curious what you
discovered you know what I mean yeah
well it's a challenge when you write it
that way I mean I did that with the
first movie I directed also
um in a sense they're both more like
novels in a way and there are benefits
to that potentially where for example in
the dead don't hurt there are characters
that you see at the beginning
die but then you get to see them in past
scenes as it goes along whether it's
Wilkins or whether it's Kendall and you
get to know them and you think oh wow or
an advantages for example there's a
scene I don't think this gives away too
much where Weston played by Sally McLeod
who's our villain who's really great
he comes to pay her I've visited on a
beautiful Sunday you know morning and
she's in the garden working and he's
coming he's very polite and gentlemanly
and she has an instinct she sees him
coming and there's a look on her face
that's really great you can't explain
that how that's acted and there's just a
feeling there something's not
something's off but then he's kind of
charming but the audience already knows
and that he's not a good guy and they're
thinking no no no no don't talk to him
she's alone with this guy so there's an
advantage to that kind of structure
and like you say when you get in the
editing room sometimes it's like wow
that's a mess I don't know I did think
about it I you know at one point I was
struggling with especially the first
third of the movie because that's the
crucial establishing who she is where
she comes from how do we do that I don't
know if it's going to work I scripted or
not uh and I tried different things I
even thought about linear and I actually
we did a rough of linear and I didn't
like it so I went back to it it was just
a question of finding the Rhythm it's
kind of like music I mean I had before I
started directing I had more experience
with music for years editing and I
realized even on the first movie I
directed it's not very different uh uh
you know editing music it's about
finding the right Rhythm okay that
that's too many notes take that one away
now it goes that's the transition boom
boom boom boom the beat is that
and that's the way I found editing
images was very similar and actors you
know it's like there's a rhythm there's
a rhythm there that they're telling you
you have to find that and and in both
cases
I composed most of the score
before we started shooting and so the
music dictated in many cases how the
scenes were shot how many shots and how
we approached it you know I'm curious
for you what was it like what surprised
you about working with Vigo as a
director and what was he like when he
was not getting exactly what he was
looking for apparently you are looking
for
you're looking for the story we had so
much trouble
with him no I'm actually no I was gonna
say I'm not looking for that but I'm
curious what I know but that is very
interesting and yes you're right and
there's something no but it yes yes so
it was like working with someone who's
somehow very close to maybe the core of
my being or maybe their Sims
some spirituality or some like um a soft
side for nature and that we share so
that I always maybe felt because I I
didn't know you but I knew your work and
you can tell that through your work
but at the same time of course it's
someone who's completely opposite
so yes it was not only easy and it was
not only oh yes I know exactly what you
want I'm going to do like there was a
lot of um Me Maybe not doing what you
want also me often I was I was
consciously trying to
how do you call that like hint again
almost like almost like I would sneak
something behind his back but but
playfully you know like like waiting for
him to notice and then go like okay is
he going to be angry or is he gonna
laugh about it you know like the way
you're playing with with someone and
that to me because for me acting is play
so and and it's one thing to be a good
actor and know your lines and be perfect
and be correct but then what I mean I I
don't say that's bad just I find it
boring and so what I always look for is
something real
so what I would like to do is like um
you know when he came back from war
The Way It Was Written it didn't tell
you how it should be made but you
naturally think she will be happy
then he's back
and we did the scene the first time and
I remember you could hear a pin drop
because every one of the crew was like
who's happening why is she not happy
and then it made sense to everyone and
it made it perfect complete sense and
then the whole scene came from there
them just being completely silent
because they don't know what to say and
they haven't spoken he hasn't spoken
probably no your instincts are great and
the way you were with the boy everything
and that helped me acting in the scene
to react to you and this boy so yeah you
want you want actors crew members to to
come with surprises something more
because if it's just your blueprint and
just what you have in your mind you're
just one person it's a collective art
form and when people come with something
that challenges you even if it annoys
you sometimes you're like what the hell
is that why is she doing that yeah and
then you stop and think and it's like
actually that's pretty interesting if
she does that that means that this
happens
yeah why not yeah you know so if you're
open you get many gifts if you're closed
it's all annoying I actually thought
that sequence played very real and
authentic specifically because I I
because of everything that the
characters have been through there's a
lot anyway I thought it was a very well
done scene well it's like um if I could
if I may say but it's like dancing I
think a lot in acting
so and the best dance partner is someone
who can hold against you like to who you
can lean on to or you can pull like it
was equally strong
and I think if it if it's annoying what
I do that's also a great thing because
then it even becomes something you can
feel something like it becomes something
you can you know
yeah it's also because it's in that time
and it's something that people would
have no idea about I mean I still
send postcards and letters and people
don't do that much anymore it's like
people like using the telegraph or
something but I like the physical
writing and the receiving the miracle of
will this postcard get to by the way
thank you for the Postcard oh you're the
last one I got it yeah you're welcome
and so but but but what they're talking
about now you realize it's not just and
people freak out if you don't do a like
or to respond to the email within an
hour or two or that day but here are
people who've been to apart for a few
years and it's like did you get my
letters I got seven the last one got wet
so I couldn't read it because the ink
ran you know that's that reality then
that people would have a hard time
imagining now and just a few lines
paints a whole image of what that
existence was like I like when
you give a hint of something whether
it's the actor does it or the writing
does it
and you trust the audience to put the
rest together you know
um that they can participate in the
storytelling because I I thought about
this last night again when we showed the
movie and then afterwards when people
are talking to us about what they felt
what they saw once you've shown it it's
not your movie anymore it's their movie
and they decided what it's about and
especially if you leave gaps and you
have a challenging structure they build
they know what your past is for
themselves in a different way than we
could imagine sometimes and I think
that's great yeah I also appreciated
that it was an unconventional Western
because I've seen so many westerns and
this you know I I love movies where I
don't know where it's all going to go
you know what I mean in the non-linear
structure and the fact that it's not
about you know it's about two anyway I I
really enjoyed it it's not about a guy
going to war it's about
the person who doesn't go to war what
happens there that's not what you
usually see you know 100
um because I'm just about out of time I
am curious from when you started writing
the script to what people see on screen
how much is it what you originally
imagined like how much did you find in
the writing if you know you know what I
mean like along the way that became the
movie and how much were you thinking
about this is where I want to go it's if
you allow it it's always writing as you
go along it's you write it you have the
idea you write it you rewrite it someone
reads it they react to it they say I'll
do it then you start thinking of it in a
new way then you start to see them doing
it and other people doing it and then
the cinematographer comes in with this
point of view and the costume designer
and the Productions Etc et cetera the
client in this case the cinematographer
almost defines the writing you know like
the way I saw that yesterday the way he
films me in certain moments and chooses
of what to see and how not to some like
he's looking after Vivian it's like the
cameras the camera cares for Vivian
looks after Vivian tries to protect her
and this continues in the editing you
keep writing and you keep finding ways
you know like whether it's the structure
or which shots to show of Vivian for
example how she reacts do we see her
when or do we just hear her react
sometimes you know completely listen I
could ask you a million other questions
but you have to do another interview and
I do too so I'm just going to say a
sincere congratulations I and I look
forward to whatever you're going to
write and direct next congratulations on
your performance and congrats for being
a part of Tiff thank you thank you for
tuning in look for more interviews on
collider soon